[Music]
howdy from dallas-fort worth I've
arrived after about 12 hours of
traveling and it turns out that Ricky
has flown into the wrong Airport so he's
about to get an uber from wherever the
he is to where I am and then we're
gonna pick up the car it is over five
and a half liters it's a soft top we
don't know what it is should go get this
path and see that's nice but hardtop
that's nice that's probably what we
would have got that's us
[Music]
a luggage situation price that you pay
buying a silly car while you're on
holiday arrived our hotel for the first
night I said to Ricky that I really
wanted to stay in one of those kind of
seedy dodgy American motel type things
news like yeah yeah cool one of the
nights we should definitely do that
didn't realize the he-men on the first
night so we are staying here comes with
its own serial killer looks like the
exterior of every murder documentary
ever made good morning from Dallas I
have woken up with my anal integrity
intact and no visible diseases after our
nights in the Bates Motel
we're here at bar Becks the only
respectable way to have beer for
breakfast but we are getting the world's
largest coffee then we are heading to
the Arboretum and Botanical Gardens and
then we are going to rainbow vomit Art
Gallery later on to meet rainbow rock so
exciting day ahead and then we got three
and a half hour drive to go to Houston
that is a happy man right there
bottomless coffee a plate that's larger
than my head outstanding well the best
thing about my day is a suppressor
booked this happens
[Music]
never gonna get bored of that there is a
ho shoot going on wedding photo heroes
II maybe maybe maybe an actual wedding
it's hot I meant that she's hot we've
managed to find a petting zoo which has
some of the prettiest little animals
I've ever seen Ricky managed to
sweet-talk the guy in the front door
he's got a VIP entry what's this guy's
name Holly what's this girl's name sorry
Holly really awkwardly I've just missed
gendered Holly here got strong jawline
ah Lisa can't really blame me but you
[Music]
that's a bit of you Martin this one this
one he's so fluffy
[Music]
very unique
and not really an art guy but then you
get to ride a rainbow unicorn in a room
filled with clouds it's a good day I
think I could get into some art you know
so we're going to go train before we
drive from Dallas to Houston later on
today but because we packed all of our
into our suitcases
I'm taking my suitcase and so is he to
the gym these look like the keenest
CrossFitters in history hi I've come to
train I also have brought all of my
worldly possessions with me as well what
a pair of situation
[Music]
[Applause]
first half done that was a bit deceptive
lunges got really heavy really fast and
then tried to do the same weight for the
lunges on tricep extensions stupid
next up five rounds fifty double unders
50 foot dumbbell front rack walking
lunge fifty seconds of shoulder taps
rest for two minutes five rounds it's
really really ugly in the heat Ricky had
a little accident sit outside for a
minute
he was doing handstand walks and
muscle-ups is like our X plus plus plus
though oh yeah nice to get swollen need
to have a shower try and cool off and
then we are setting off to Houston
between a half hour drive to Houston so
we'll get it done together get set up
with a Space Center tomorrow we are half
way from Dallas to Houston and one of
Ricky's friends messaged him and said
Earth is this food restaurant place
exactly halfway on the route you've got
to go there you got to stop off so we've
pulled in and I can kind of see why it
is an entire parking lot and estate for
one restaurant it has its own
merchandise it's called rookies I have
no idea what this place is but we're
gonna try it out what I'm excited about
it I'm very excited
[Music]
so it's kind of like a supermarket but
food supermarket for every type of food
nuts roasted nuts desserts over there
sodas over there sweets over there and
then ice cream porch food brisket
a lot brisket this place is epic